[Musik]
mein name ist raus war ich 13 jahre alt
und macht momentan jetzt meine
ausbildung als verkäufer ich bin kein
wasser huberty und bin seit oktober 2013
marktleiter ein guter verkäufer muss auf
jeden fall sehr gut umgehen können wie
beraten können und dementsprechend auch
bei dieser problem helfen können das
zwischen werden er muss dem kunden
vermitteln dass er sich hier wohl fühlen
kann und dass er auch immer wieder
kommen kann
[Musik]
im einzelhandel geht es um waren und den
verkauf von verschiedenen produkten wie
zum beispiel obst wurst
käse
und getränken
verkäufer müssen die waren die sie
verkaufen sehr gut kennen
auch die warenkontrolle ist eine
wichtige aufgabe des verkäufers denn der
kunde will immer frische produkte kaufen
[Musik]
verkaufs- und beratungsgespräche mit
kunden sind wichtig auch das bestellen
von waren
die warenannahme und das kassieren mehr
über den beruf des verkäufers erfahrt
ihr im nächsten teil